- [Announcer] This Great Big Story
was made possible by Shell.
Make the future.
- [Narrator] The wheel.
A perfect function
invented in the Stone Age.
To this day, the wheel
provides the same function
as it did those thousands of years ago,
but one man is flipping
everything we knew about the wheel
on its head.
- My name is Michael Burtov.
I'm not an engineer, but
I did what most engineers
wish they could.
(gentle music)
When I was a little kid I
liked to take things apart
and see what they're made out of.
I tried to make something new out of them.
And I still like doing it to this day.
In 2012, I was running an HR company,
and I turned on the movie, "Tron."
I was drinking a coffee, and I thought,
"Those are very cool
motorcycles in the movies."
They're called light cycles,
and they have these hollow wheels,
and I remember thinking, well,
I'm not an engineer but
couldn't we do something useful
with that empty space?
I imagined you could
put things in the wheel
that lived outside of it
with an electric wheel.
For example, the motor and the battery.
A wheel that powers itself is
a much more universal wheel
than a wheel that needs
something else to power it.
Make it super compact, super efficient,
and that's really what inspired me.
Pretty much everyone
said it was impossible.
They said that if it could be done,
it would have been done
already by a real engineer.
So I ignored them, and I quit my job
and then I met Dakota Decker,
who ended up leaving SpaceX
to build the wheel together with me.
Dakota and I spent about two years
before we came to the version
that we put out for retail.
It's a much more compact design.
Takes up the same space as a regular wheel
but has got everything in
it, the entire power train,
the battery, the motor, the computer.
This wheel is extremely
environmentally friendly.
It's electric powered, and
it's a very efficient use.
We have made thousands of bicycles
into affordable, electric
vehicles all over the world.
We see that we can
contribute to the future
of transportation with
the GeoOrbital wheel.
We see vehicles that
nobody has ever made before
being able to be made now.
Imagine a car, imagine the possibilities
when you take all the guts out of a car
'cause you just don't need them anymore.
The opportunity's really are endless.
(dramatic music)